trying to go 17-0 but we're gonna be
taking the quarterback last so let's
trust the process the colts give me
jonathan taylor the pretty good start
got the best running back in the league
so let's see what we're getting next i
don't want the bengals give me jamar
chase jonathan taylor jamar chase that's
what i'm talking about great two first
picks let's go with the rams okay give
me cooper cup now these skill positions
are looking elite like this is excellent
so far guys i'm feeling hyped the bills
give me the defense now i'm not gonna
lie i could have one with stefan dix
there but we already got two elite
receivers and i need some defense
cardinals give me diony hopkins lie just
based off of this by itself this team is
going 17-0 i'm not gonna lie to you guys
the patriots okay give me hunter henry
hey we just need the o-line next come on
give me somebody that's solid
the giants offensive line
ah it all comes down to this come on man
don't do me dirty don't do me mess oh my
god